today we're going to talk about sugar I
do not think people are aware of how
much sugar they're putting in their
bodies and their family's bodies take a
look at right up here we have peanut
marshmallows number those things as a
child 280 grams of sugar both of these
combined right here could even fit them
to one cup and then we get apple juice
apple juice has 264 grams of sugar I
mean how many kids at parties at the
school they're drinking the apple juice
thinking it's better than soda when in
fact it seems to be it has more sugar
both of these combined right here and
then we got Coke 136 grams of sugar that
Arizona 120 grams right here you can get
this at the dollar store for a buck
which a lot of this contains high
fructose corn syrup all right now high
for just corn syrup is a lot cheaper
than actual sugar that's why they're
using it now it's like 20 cents a pound
an average person consumes about 63
pounds of hyper just corn syrup every
single year
frosted our notes F Froot Loops I'd like
to know how much fruit is in Froot Loops
I don't think any but they have fiber
and whole grains
so this Froot Loops has 96 grams of
sugar now the other thing you need to
make a note on is that some of these
refined grains like flour products might
not have a lot of sugar but they have a
lot of grains which isn't listed in the
sugar content so when you evaluate the
food at the grocery store when you buy
it always look at the sugar amounts okay
a little sugar on the nutrient facts
it'll have sugar grams that's the most
important thing to look at and you want
that as close to zero as possible and
then you want to realize that serving
size per cup and then it says how many
servings per container so you have to
multiply eight serving per container
times the number of sugars to get the
true amount so if you're just looking at
the sugars it's not 12 grams for the
whole box it's 12 times 8 which is 96
scrams okay then we have nutrigrain
nutrigrain blueberry right it says made
with real fruit but but realize that
there's so much sugar in here 96 grams
there's a little bit of blueberry
flavoring and puree that's pretty much
about it then we have orange drink
that's 91 grams of sugar you can get
this for a buck at the dollar store and
it has a lot of high fructose corn syrup
and then we have chocolate fudge soda 80
grams and then check this out Similac
this is baby formula and what's
interesting is I try to find the sugar
grams you can't find it I don't know why
but if you look on the label it'll have
total carbohydrates but it won't have
total sugars so I'm just taking the
total carbohydrates assuming that sugar
beats simply because it's made the first
ingredient is corn syrup and then soy
protein isolates so anytime it's the
first ingredient it's the most material
in the product okay so we have baby
formula and then we have Gatorade 58
grams of sugar dextrose they use
dextrose and sucrose those sugars tend
to deplete electrolytes so sugar one of
the facts is it depletes potassium it
depletes calcium and it depletes B
vitamins when you deplete your potassium
your relative sodium goes up so you
retain sodium and that's why you can
gain a pound to weight after eating just
a little bit of sugar because of the
fluid retention and we get vitamin water
31 grams I mean an average coca-cola 8
ounce can of coca-cola has 38 grams this
has 31 not much less and again these
they should call it synthetic vitamin
water good it's all synthetic vitamins
check this out hidden sugar in flavored
yogurt 26 grams of sugar that's really
only 10 grams well 12 grams less than a
coke there's a lot of sugar in this
thing
here and then Activia 25 grams of sugar
and then we have ensure we have 23 grams
of sugar with a lot of synthetic
vitamins so when you take sugar cane
itself you have tremendous amounts of
nutrition which will never produce tooth
decay because of all the vitamins and
minerals in in the sugar cane so when
they separate it out into white sugar
the other part of sugar is molasses okay
and then they have different varying
degrees of how much of molasses versus
white sugar brown sugar you have a raw
sugar and you have really dark molasses
but molasses is still high in sugar as
well but it had at least it has
nutrition so it's not going to form any
negative effects with tooth decay - and
when you bake with molasses you're more
satisfied because of the fact that has
more nutrition it's hard to eat a lot of
it it's easier to eat a lot of refined
sugar because there's no nutrients to
turn off the brains hunger okay so when
you eat foods high in sugar you tend to
want to eat more and more and more of it
because there's no nutrition so it
depletes various things so the other
thing I want to mention the effect of
sugar is this thing called insulin
insulin regulates sugar by getting the
sugar out of the blood fast when you
take this much sugar in in one sitting
for example you're going to have massive
whiplash of certain organs like your
pancreas that flood that insulin and and
spike it to drop the sugar and what it's
doing is taking the sugar putting it in
storage is fat triglycerides cholesterol
okay that's what it's doing so when the
blood sugar goes up and your insulin
goes up to counter it you start to
create fatigue within the whole system
and over time it lose the control and
then you end up with low blood sugar
that's the first step that's like a
pre-diabetic it's called hypoglycemia
low hypo meaning low blood sugar
glycemic means sugar so we have the
situation we have low blood sugar so
here are the symptoms craving sweets
okay that's a pre-diabetic State craving
sweets all the time then we have here
too
anxiety depression a DD hyperactivity
those are all signs of pre-diabetes
because it's hypoglycemia and what
happens is that over time you start
creating more and more damage with the
system and now the insulin doesn't work
so now things stay high in the sugar
hyperglycemia that's called diabetes why
because you don't have enough insulin to
push it down so the symptoms for high
blood sugar would be fatigue brain fog
much like you would feel after a
Thanksgiving meal so you have this
lethargy this brain fog this fatigue all
right and that's diabetes and that's why
they take certain drugs metformin and
even insulin to start lowering the blood
sugar the problem with that is that once
you're diabetic because the sugars
aren't regulated there's a lot of side
effects with vision you go blind
eventually because it affects the nerves
in the eye the optic nerve it affects
the circulation in the outer fingertips
and the feet so you start getting pain
in your feet tingling it's called
peripheral neuropathy eventually losing
circulation eventually losing your toes
to gangrene this is a lot of about
affects not just weight gain and in the
presence of just a little bit of sugar
because sugar and insulin I'm sorry
because insulin is a dominating hormone
you can do a lot of good things with
your diet and all it takes is a little
bit of that bad thing especially as you
age to create huge countering effects so
in a little bit of sugar will block a
lot of good things that you do so you
can be exercising eating good and
sleeping and just a little bit of sugar
will bump you out of fat-burning for a
long time depending on your metabolism
now when you're 18 you can get away with
it like myself because all I ate growing
up was sugar sugar sugar I would live on
these foods and that's why I got in
health because I burnt my body out I
lasted till I was 28 I met a patient
yesterday in fact and she lasted till
she was like 48 and she she's been
living in triggering all eyes and
finally I caught up with her and now she
has diabetes and all these other
problems so that's what's motivating her
so I'm not saying you can't have all
these things but all I'm saying is I
want you to be aware of what's going to
occur and be willing to experience those
negative effects
be more cognitive when you eat this
thing versus being slightly asleep when
you're eating and getting into that
social mode where you all of a sudden
you realize oh my gosh what did I just
do so I want you to become more aware of
what you do when you consume this and
realize that how much damage it creates
now there's a couple things that you can
do to get rid of cravings number one you
can consume more potassium I just wrote
a book and you could download this free
off my website called the kale shake
diet it's 12 pages it's a free book and
there's nothing in here to buy you can
download it off my website you can also
come my office and just get one free but
it's very very simple you should get
your friends and family just to do this
one simple thing make a kale shake in
the morning and that starts to spike
your potassium because potassium is the
mineral that will help reduce the
cravings to sugar why because it helps
to prevent a low blood sugar situation
so so it's very important to have a lot
of potassium in the diet so that that
way you won't want as much sugar and
when you're burning when you're actually
craving sugar you're not burning fat so
just realize that if you're trying to
lose weight and you're still craving
sugar then there's you're not really
burning fat you're just burning up your
sugar and then you eat more sugar and
it's a never-ending process true fat
burning you have milk cravings for sugar
that's just an FYI now the best
sweetener that I I use I like the
xylitol don't give it to your dog it's
interesting as a side effect on dogs but
for you it tastes very just like sugar
you can use it in your baking and things
like that I highly recommend something
like this and you know for your kids and
things get some recipes and do it that
way and another point I want to bring up
it's so funny how you have people let's
say well dr. Burke I'm doing I wouldn't
tell foods that I'm doing organic foods
of course come to find out those organic
treats are made with agave nectar
coconut syrup and brown rice syrup those
are it's still sugar it's still going to
create a similar effect so just because
this organic doesn't mean it's okay to
consume another point is that through
3% of children are becoming diabetic
that's crazy
we never had this when I was growing up
there's been this huge spike of more and
more and more sugary drinks it's the
sugar that's the culprit so basically in
closing what I want to talk about is I
want to show you some interesting ads
that you can you probably saw growing up
you know when you were younger number
one there's this ad that says that the
importance of sugar this is right here
in a timely matter in families and meals
nutritional findings show that your need
for nature's own sweetener is as
deep-seated as human body's need for
energy it's only 18 calories and here's
another one why so many weight watchers
find sugar a spoon full of prevention
what prompts Weight Watchers to take
sugar in their beverage and a light
dessert now and then well it may look
like cheating but they're really making
their diet easier to stick to that's
because sugar helps prevent you from
overeating it satisfies your appetite
much faster than other foods with sugar
in your diet you're happier with smaller
portions and everything you try and
that's hilarious because again they
don't realize that the insulin effect is
so dominating it's so powerful
the whole calorie counting thing is a
joke how about this one for a better
start and life tried Cola early earlier
how soon is soon not soon enough
laboratories tests I'd love to see these
laboratory tests over the past few years
has been proven that babies who start
drinking soda during the early formative
period have a much higher chance of
gaining acceptance and fitting in during
those awkward preteens and teens so do
yourself a favor do your child a favor
start them on a strict regimen I love
that strict of soda and other sugary
carbonated beverages right now for a
lifetime of guaranteed happiness
guaranteed how about this one pure
pleasure give some 7up and you're into
your kids it's so wholesome mix it with
milk see this is this is the problem the
apparently marketing works so here's the
thing here's what I want you to do
spread this video to your friends and
family go through your cupboards go
through your refrigerator start getting
the sugar out of your body it's it has
major effects not just on your body but
your weight your vitality your energy so
I hope this video helped you to increase
your awareness spread the word and I'll
see you in the next video